So the answe to this question is the last
three answers, all of them. Now why is that?
[UNKNOWN],
the first answer says there's no genetic component at
all. We just saw in of the previous exercises
that there is a concordance rate between Monozygotic twins
indicating a genetic component. Just because we didn't find anything
in the study. Doesn't actually mean there's not a
genetic component. It could be that there's so many alleles.
With each individual allele having a very small effect
that we need even bigger studies more than just thousands.
Maybe tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people for us to identify the alleles that have the
effect. We could also be looking at the wrong
variations. Perhaps we need more SNV's to look at or
maybe that there are bigger mutations we need to
focus on like chromosomal translocations
or gene duplications, deletions, insertions.
These are detectable by just looking at single nucleotide
changes. And there could always be more complicated hereditary processes,
hiding simple genetic effects. If there's anything
this lesson has taught you. I hope it's
a, there are many traits that are complex and they don't fit our simple rules
of dominant and recessive. And while this
can make it really difficult to understand or
follow, it's what gives us all the beautiful
uniqueness of each human being on the planet.